i met you a long a long time ago i think
i was one of your first
talk show appearances
uh way back in the day and you've always
been
um very stylish and sort of blazing a
trail i
i in my opinion in style you always look
so fantastic
some people say that you're responsible
for the ugg craze
because you were one of the first people
famous people to wear uggs
out and around with anything once i
discovered that there was a shoe that
felt like a slipper that you could wear
on the street
there was no turning back because i i
actually love comfort i'm gonna i'm
gonna show you a secret this is very
elegant on the top but look it's a
tracksuit
i like it so but i'm curious you were
i think you were i remembered i
remembered seeing a picture of you
looking very beautiful and you're
wearing a short i think a short skirt if
i remember correctly
and uggs with short skirt and it worked
but it felt like
you you just knew it would work when if
you just if someone described that to me
i would say no that's not going to work
but it worked it was beautiful
thanks i don't know how to respond to
that other than thank you
i i think i did just wear them with
everything to the point where they'd
slightly kind of collapsed inwards
and i've probably got my back because
i've aged but still i wear them
well my only question is have you been
compensated
by the ugg people because that's a very
uh
powerful company they make a lot of
money i'm hoping
that they have cut you in for a piece of
the ugg empire because you deserve
it the uggpie they have not they send me
free boots
occasionally but no there is no slice of
that pie so i think we should start the
make a sienna ambassador ugg campaign
but yes yeah sienna if you'd like
i'm very powerful in show business uh in
america
and um well parts of america
um a very small part of america i'm very
powerful
if you'd like i'll get involved and i
will secure you
a piece of the ugg empire okay yes thank
you